c'est barbara prat vie qui a chanté une
chanson de barbara regarde
[Musique]
suis ma voix la même assise mais gagner
c'est fini nous voilà dans le bruit et
de fureur aussi
[Musique]
agusti des espaces de l'état aussi
bouleversé ce parce que l'histoire qu'il
raconte barbara c'est la mienne aussi
et pour moi c'est elle qui représente la
france aujourd'hui c'est la chanson
française par excellence pour moi c'est
bon alors c'est une chanson de chose à
[ __ ] je veux un peu laurence boccolini
je suis franchement on voulait pas raté
grand chose parce que cette soirée et
excusez moi et c'était d'un ennui savent
absolue fera quand même qu'un jour il
m'a été prompte heures dans laxe parce
que c'est insupportable d'avoir un
concours de strabisme entre l'animateur
la garde à gauche l'autre à droite et
stéphane que j'aime beaucoup
excusez moi ont été atomisés par
boccolini disparaît complètement
d'animation c'était dangereux
et tout ça pour alors elle est très bien
la chanteuse mais en dehors de ça quel
ennui excusez moi alors moi je vais vous
dire que moi ouais c'est vrai j'ai dit
ouais mais à un moment je me suis pas
ennuyé c'est quand on a vu ce candidat
que moi je pense moi j'aurais voulu que
ce soit lui qui soit choisi pour moi
c'était lui qui met rigoler regardez mes
poils est la bienvenue à la soirée de
sélection officielle eurovision france
alors un nouvel artiste maintenant sur
sept c'est un véritable hymne à la paix
qu'il s'apprête à nous offrir en direct
alors sera-t-il notre représentant à
l'eurovision
[Applaudissements]
toulouse
[Musique]
c'est très difficile c'est une émotion
incroyable je m'attendais pas à pour
dénoncer les claques
alors j'ai d'abord pensé téléspectateurs
oui je fais dire un truc important
j'espère que notre mini de la culture a
vu cette soirée parce qu'il ya du public
en fait dresser vrai ben ouais donc je
comprends pas comment le service public
peut avoir du du public gip à couper
qu'il n'y en a pas dans les théâtres et
prénom de odile stationner masquer tout
se passe bien et bon pourquoi donc dans
les prénoms mais bon on est content pour
eux on faisait un franchement ouais mais
je trouve que c'est c'est bizarre on va
parce qu'on pensait d'être spectateur
mais shop est d'accord il ya eu beaucoup
de tweets dans ce sens le revinois avez
vous aimé les bénéfices de la vente vous
qu alinghi
voilà 50 % non à 48% rui fernandès avec
c'est important de dire que barbara pour
avis était la grande favorite elle est
très connue dans le métier à la faisait
les premières parties de florent pagny
et c'est elle qui a écrit les chansons
bim bam boum et j'imagine bien sa gueule